i spent 80 on embroidery equipment back
in march
but then i just stared at my phone and i
looked up and
now it's october i've always wanted to
cook more so i bought a 400
chef's knife i only used to open amazon
packages
for many of us the isolation of the
pandemic led to plans and projects
left unfinished with those failures
fresh on our minds we may be skeptical
of our new year's resolutions but as
christina raffini shows us
sometimes the goals we set for ourselves
aren't what we should be aiming for
these are my lovely roller skates out of
work and stuck in her charleston south
carolina home
amanda oliver had a plan to make
quarantine better
i got these really colorful roller
skates i was really excited
and literally like put them on and fell
over
you didn't have a job you were stuck at
home and the answer was roller skates
also i i tried to convince myself that i
could do woodworking
she could not i did try to make it
festive with some tinsel for the
holidays
like so many of the projects people
tried to do in 2020
it was a coveted fail it did kind of
teach me that i also tried to do
so much at once in washington dc
diplomat elod
strohlmeyer thought he'd use lockdown to
finally write his novel
when covid happened i said now it's time
i'm sitting at home let's start
something
alas i'm on page four page four page
four
you think of new year resolution so
maybe that's a covid resolution whatever
you want to call it
and then reality hits and all of a
sudden you realize it's harder than you
think
what is it about human psychology that
for years and years and years myself
included
we've said if i only had the time and we
finally had the time
and we didn't do it i think one of the
problems is that covet 19 messes with
our sense of time in these really
interesting ways
dr lori santos is a professor of
psychology at yale
and host of the podcast the happiness
lab
she says if you want to have a better
2021
start by cutting yourself some slack
especially around the new year
we often have goals that involve some
kind of like
complete self overhaul it's like a time
when we tell ourselves that
we really kind of suck and we need to
kind of get it in here
and the problem is that the the science
really shows that that approach to
setting goals
just doesn't work turns out forgiving
your failures can actually help you
accomplish more
you want to set goals but in a way
that's a little bit self-compassionate
quarantines in a new apartment greg
thurner learned surprisingly
he's really bad at puzzles i'm really
good at
opening puzzles and dumping the pieces
out as far as making a picture out of
them that takes a little bit more time
but he also found something he was good
at practicing piano
which he hasn't done regularly since he
was a kid being realistic about my goals
and setting my goals
to be something attainable in a
reasonable amount of time has made them
very fulfilling
are you putting a little less pressure
on yourself i'd like to think so
yeah and stro meyer decided not to beat
himself up about his four-page non-novel
instead he spent more time outside with
his husband
touring america's national parks it's
not all about
big resolutions that this year i'm going
to do a b and c
this year i'm going to finish my book
it's about being happy
and whole with what you want to do and
that's the good part about
failing during covid everybody's doing
it
so we didn't feel like oh i'm trying
this thing and everybody else is doing
it perfectly
it kind of felt like everybody's just
sort of trying stuff and so why not give
stuff a try
so she tried for a new job and landed
the position
even though her skating positions still
leave a lot
to be desired for cbs this morning
saturday
christina raffini washington i really
like that piece
good to move forward and move on it's
one of my favorite lines from my
favorite show of the year ted lasso
which is you know why the goldfish is
the happiest animal on earth
why why is the goldfish the happiest
animal 10 second memory
i love it did you guys try anything new
um
i honestly feel like there were moments
where i got very sluggish like there
were the ups and then just like when i'm
tired i'm
exhausted and i'm like oh my gosh does
anybody stick with resolutions
um sometimes okay okay
i don't really set them so much it's
like overall
hopes for the future right